si le nombre de cas de contamination
augmente aujourd'hui partout en europe
c'est vers l'espagne que tous les
regards se tournent avec douze mille
nouveaux cas quotidiens c'est dans la
péninsule ibérique que le virus circule
le plus activement sur le continent si
les hôpitaux ne sont pas saturés pour le
moment certains professionnels tirent la
sonnette d'alarmé
et qu'en est il alors de l'italie
berceau de l'épidémie en europe au mois
de mars dernier
aujourd'hui les chiffres transalpins
sont presque six fois inférieur à ce que
l'on connaît ailleurs ce qui pourrait
s'expliquer par la prudence dont font
preuve les italiens aujourd'hui c'est la
rentrée scolaire et les écoliers ont
déjà des cours de distanciation sociale
les enfants sont prêts premier jour
d'école primaire pour ma fille
indépendamment des masques on espère que
tout se passe bien
oui oui tout a déjà été fait alors
masques supplémentaires au cas où du gel
des lingettes désinfectantes
tout est prêt dans son sac à dos
espérons que cela se passe bien mais pas
seulement à cet égard mais en général
j'espère qu'ils vont apprendre tous
ensemble et qu'ils vont apprendre à
partager en communauté nous saurons
d'ici la fin de l'année
en france aussi c'est la hausse des
hospitalisations inquiète
une inquiétude accentuée par les
dernières déclarations du directeur de
la branche européenne de l'om s selon
lui le nombre de morts va augmenter ces
prochains mois en europe et un vaccin
s'il est découvert ne sera pas vraiment
la solution miracle
j'entends tout le temps le vaccin va
être la fin de l'épidémie bien sûr que
non nous ne savons même pas si le vaccin
va être efficace dans toutes les parties
de la population certains signes que
nous recevons sont qu'il sera efficace
pour certains mais pas pour d'autres
et c'est du coup nous avons commandé des
vaccins différents quel cauchemar
logistique
si le nombre de cas de contamination
augmente significativement sur le
continent les décès eux restent aux
niveaux observés en juin dernier
aujourd'hui entre 400 et 500 personnes
meurent chaque jour en europe du
coronavirus les états européens membres
de l' oms se rassemblent jusqu'à ce soir
le but de cette rencontre est changée et
élaborer une stratégie commune pour
contrer la nouvelle vague épidémique